look up on the screen it's a bird it's a
plane it's it's Superman lives where did
this fight scene come from warning
spoilers ahead with his long-awaited DC
Comics Blockbuster The Flash finally
racing across the Finish Line into
theaters across the country director
Andy musketti has given Superman fans
one of the most shocking surprises ever
at least it would have been shocking if
he hadn't spoiled it weeks ahead of the
film's release yes we're talking about
that jaw-dropping head scratching Cameo
appearance from none other than Nicholas
Cage and the role of the Man of Steel
much a was made of his inclusion in the
film after muskete leaked the news while
both the scene and the uproarious
reaction from fans may have been
confusing for casual observers it's
actually a reference to an almost
mythological DC Comics project that was
shelved many many years ago having
existed only through vague Recollections
and test footage fans familiar with the
project have likely been in the clouds
themselves imagining what it might look
like when they finally get a glimpse at
the Superman film that might have been
then again now that they've actually had
a chance to see the scene for themselves
in the context of the even Multiverse
story of The Flash they may now be
questioning if it's worth all the hay in
Smallville for those experiencing the
legend of Nicolas Cage's Superman For
the First Time In The Flash will briefly
recap its long confusing history and
development hell The Story Goes that hot
off the success of his indie film clerks
Kevin Smith was contacted by Warner
Brothers to write a new Superman film
within the universe of Tim Burton's
Batman series later in the process
Burton himself would even be attached to
direct under the prospective title
Superman lives according to Smith
producer John Peters felt that Superman
as a character was too queer-coded which
is a nice way of saying they kept
referring to the character with
homophobic slurs in his production notes
because of this bigoted anxiety Peters
gave Smith three non-negotiable
parameters for a story one I don't want
to see him in that suit
two I don't want to see him fly
and three he's gotta fight a giant
spider in the third act unfortunately
these were far from the last bizarre
note Smith or Burton would hear during
production most of which concern the
addition of scenes and characters that
were just there to sell merchandise
either because of genuine quality
concerns a rapidly inflating budget or a
lack of confidence following the abysmal
response to 1997's Batman and Robin
Superman lives was shelved for good in
1998 doomed to tease fans for 25 years
but now that we have some part of this
promise finally fulfilled was it really
worth all the hype well no the problem
with the lightning pass Superman live
sequence is the same problem that
follows the rest of the forced cameos in
the flash the scene plays out with
Cage's Superman fighting off a giant
spider and once he defeats the spider he
just looks directly at the screen the
idea seems to be that these Cameo worlds
will be destroyed if the Flash doesn't
undo his time travel actions but it's
introduced so last minute that it never
had as much weight as it should have
even ignoring the fact that the CGI
model for cage is far from perfect the
scene itself is merely slapped on the
outside of the story with no setup
payoff or impact if you're looking for a
meaningful Glimpse at Tim Burton and
Kevin Smith scrap Superman projects
you're likely going to be disappointed
however for those of us that go to these
Multiverse films to Feast on as many
Easter eggs as we possibly can Nicholas
Cage's uncanny turn to Superman makes a
flash every bit the Masterpiece it was
said to be
foreign